well guys another Marvel movie to talk
about awesome I mean there's so many of
these things lately and they're almost
all great
this one's ant-man hmm ant-man ant-man
this is a project that has been in so
many different hands this movie has gone
through a lot of people namely the
biggest one Edgar Wright this was
originally gonna be written and directed
by him and was already written and there
was even test footage and the test
footage was great and then all of a
sudden he just was like no I don't want
to do this anymore
you know creative differences or
whatever and a lot of people cried and
it was sad and you know it was not cool
I'm a big fan of Edgar Wright and I was
really looking forward to that I think
he's a very talented writer and director
nevertheless it is now being directed by
Peyton Reed the director of bring it on
down with love the breakup and Yes Man
which doesn't provide me with a lot of
optimism this teaser though does because
Michael Douglas and Paul Rudd look great
in the movie and I really think that the
tone of this trailer is just right now
you see I said all those pessimistic
things just now about this movie that
being said if I had not seen guardians
of the galaxy last year I would
definitely be giving everything I just
said a lot of merit but I did see
guardians of the galaxy last year a
movie where a tree that says one phrase
and a talking raccoon were freakin
amazing
Marvel's at this stage where it seems
like they can make just about anything
work and for that reason I am very
excited for ant-man I am less optimistic
about the chosen director and the fact
that it's been through so many different
hands which can make the creative vision
a little bit muffled sometimes but I
like the tone the trailer shows and that
is a comedy and action adventure of vibe
all melded into one which I really think
can work based off of guardians of the
galaxy last year that being said James
Gunn doesn't really have anything to do
with this movie so there is still an air
of skepticism in me and I had to be
honest like part of me isn't like
jumping for joy about ant-man yet I have
to really see a little bit more or at
least go into the movie with an open
mind which I of course will I think Paul
Rudd will be great in the movie I think
Michael Douglas is gonna be good I think
the special effects gonna be awesome
because Marvel is doing all of that very
well nowadays and Marvel is definitely
taking a lot of care when it comes to
their characters and theirs
it's just the creative differences
throughout the years with this movie
make me slightly skeptical and a little
worried I do think it can be awesome I
think it has a lot of potential I really
hope the film reaches that potential and
this trailer does make me optimistic in
the fact that it doesn't look like
absolute garbage it looks like it can be
really fun and Paul Rudd looks really
good in the role I have a lot of
confidence in all the acting talent and
the way the film looks I'm just a little
bit more worried about the story and the
way Peyton Reed will handle action
sequences since he hasn't really done
that before
what are your guys thoughts on ant-man
I'm very curious to see what you think
and as always thank you so much for
watching guys i will have my most
anticipated of 2015 up very soon I've
just been down with kind of a nasty cold
which I'm trying to suppress for this
video I hope it worked
as always guys thank you so much for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get steppen heist